mais ce maillot du club et je fais bien
je fais vite trois petites choses
la nuit la dernière de 2017 les amis on
commence avec la mise à jour quelques
images marquantes de ces dernières 24
heures c'est partir garde hier après le
prime banos el moctar a décidé de
rentrer en stop motion arrive sur france
3 il ya une candidate qui a voulu nous
montrer ses talents de flûtistes et
c'est assez dingue et vous voulez vous
le théâtre qui sont alors allés non
plaisante c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça
c'est ça la savak dans télématin laurent
bignolas il a tenté une petite
blagounette tout en poésie
mais nathalie rihouet ça passe pas avec
lui ça normalement c'est un tacle deux
matches de suspension
nathalie un peu de douceur dans ce monde
de brume oui aujourd'hui qu'un 12
douceur dans ce monde de brute louvois
elle est bien en place et noval de la
rate et oui d'élèves en afrique isabelle
morini bosc avait commis l'irréparable
avec un mignon on a retrouvé leurs
enfants de stars la télé c'est si le
calcium
alors voyez là j'ai parlé de l ordre
dans la matinale de ces news regardent
et ont lancé un sujet sur le grand
retour de marion ah oui à l'accord
aboutisse une info incroyable pour ceux
qui aiment le sport mais il ya le gars
qui ont régi qu'il confond les images et
vu la confusion elle n'est pas près de
devenir en invité à mon avis rions
bartoli qui nous a adressé ce message
sur instagram
public sénat le député françois ruffin
il a voulu placer un petit peu de johnny
mais il se rend compte trop tard qui
connaît pas les paroles
c'est un temps que j'essaye de vivre
pleinement ce principe hérité de boby
lapointe qui vient de gagner un mètre de
l'en vie et on sait chaque matin sur bfm
jean jacques bourdin reçoit un politique
en interview bien direct sans concession
mais ce matin il a reçu le skipper
françois gabart et jean jacques a eu un
véritable coup de foudre c'est un deuil
dans françois gabart bonjour bon gendre
ça me fait plaisir de vous voir sur
terre face à moi vous approuver la
politique choisie par le gouvernement
je vous ai vu tout à l'heure vous été
appuyée contre le mur pourquoi vous
chanceler encore vous n'avez aucun
défaut non mais ça non et puis
oui
faire de la côte aux territoires où je
regardais vos mains
c'est fabuleux ça fait plaisir baptisé
en voiture au sommaire d'améridiens
safer ça va être plus par tous et je
regardais ma droite c'est pas mieux
quand tu dois je regarde niveau merde on
voit qu'il prend vache folle gmat un
petit peu le service public aussi manon
commotion est ami avec le président je
passe jélois le caillou dans la botte
des bureaux de ses parts et julien doré
il est en concert live et il s'est pris
un vent mais à leur niveau anticyclone
des açores en backstage
après le gars ont bien calmes et des
c'est un miracle mais dans une redite d'
enquête d'action a retrouvé le gars qui
est interpellé pour la raison la plus
chaude ou au monde deuxième objectif
d'interpellations qu'il est connu pour
outrage et russell juste pour info la
personne a été vu à voiron en train de
faire l'oiseau sous la pluie à trois
heures du matin en tongs un bon moment
préféré j'ai trouvé sur ciani 25 une
éleveuse de chevaux nous parle de sa
passion et soit j'ai l'esprit mal placé
soit ce qu'elle dit est vraiment bizarre
mais j'assume totalement
mais de travail je suis fier de montrer
mes fesses et je suis fier de venir mes
chevaux avec le dos à voile sur
l'interpellation il faut échanger
moisson on trouve bon cyril je sais pas
si vous le saviez avait 67 % des
français seraient prêts à tout plaquer
pour devenir pâtissier selon un sondage
que je viens d'inventer mais qui arrange
époux recensement ah oui j'ai regardé le
meilleur dossier sur ses pas la finale
c'était la préfinale ça marche donc aux
halles et il ya le débris de l'avion et
les gars étaient hyper en bois c'est
hyper angoissée pour de la pâtisserie
regarde
on a mené l enquête on sait slogan
regardez les participants sur leur écran
comprends mieux
les craintes de l'amour ils ont voulu
rendre hommage à forrest gump avec
l'expression la vie c'est comme une
boîte de chocolats visiblement ils ont
pas de fric sans que je dans la vie moi
je suis belle indécise la vie c'est pas
une botte de kidnapping tu peux pas tout
avant ça dans lesquels tu préfères j'en
étais qui m'est ils se taisent bourgeois
de l'année on la doit aller anna je suis
même pas sûr de lire en janvier tel
malherbe à table tout ça ça me dégoûte
l'eau moi c'est pas trop mon truc moi
c'est plus simple franchement est ce que
ça vaut pas les termes d'un contrat
le truc sur nathalie roux et m'a rappelé
nous l'a eu des ennuis et nathalie
rihouet en faisant des conneries avec
quels hommes et qui s'étend en avais tu
vois il y avait une image de météo où
elle faisait la carte de l'europe avec
les températures et non la f1 doublage
pour la télé c'était la liste des mais
qu'elle avait tiré donc en disait à
moscou j'ai tiré 32 mais quand ça marche
c'est vachement bien
c'est très drôle et à la fin scandale
mais un scandale ah oui c'est bien
gentil les gentils mais sur le nombre de
mecs et a tiré
en fait vous trouvez retrouvez les
chevaliers du fiel juste après que
boulogne attend métal d'attentats aux
morts non non non je vous sens un petit
peu fou j'aime ça mais je dois vous
garder jusqu'au bout donc on va se faire
un petit peu de jt pour quelle maison
commence avec un duplex particulier vous
allez voir il ya un gars qui nous parle
en fait il un duplex depuis chez lui et
il parle de l'étang qui passe juste
derrière chez lui regardé tout démarre
bien c'est en toute quiétude
c'est bucolique dans le temps du cians
sait pas bien ce qui se passe est une
coupure pub et trois minutes après c'est
une autre ambiance entre vos yeux on va
retrouver tout de suite géronde doumeng
sais pas si on sait pas toujours 9h50
désolant c'est un gros concours de
photos sur les réseaux broc organisation
à l'inter milan un carton est ce qu'on
en est du côté des pull moche parce
qu'on avait lancé ce concours les pulls
de noël un peu spéciaux puisque ça
avance nous avons une téléspectatrice
elle répondu vraiment disant nous allons
vous parler de ce qui est un 2 way et
dans un jt on a découvert notre poteau
gérard louvin il a eu un enfant de star
games amstrong est dans une étape de
montagne
on a des comptes à rendre
il y a
j'ai bon sur france 2 j'ai regardé la
version télé des grosses tami s'est
passé avant-hier exactement l'émission
qui cartonne à la radio même si cyril
vous le disiez qu'il ya une autre
édition qui fonctionne bien à la radio
c'est vrai quel autre émission une
chapelle basse et virgin tonique
toujours sous la main avec camille
combal est vrai que nous combattons pas
il voyait sa voix moi j'écoute moi
j'écoute mes amis tous les matins je me
sens suspect de grippe non non plus tous
les matins je regarde pas ce qui est
tous les matins dans tt avec ses sujets
ben oui non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
nom du matin tous les matins je vois le
sujet m'a fait pas la jeter atrides ont
été solides en ttc cartonne avec camille
tous les matins sur rihanna du travail
de ma chérie maillot et je travaille
demain j'arrête en direct dans 200 ans
après vacances et tu reprends le et on
reprend le jeudi 4 ou 6 ou qu'un truc
comme ça alors c'est toujours avant tes
peines pénales tu reprends une question
posée à embarrassant vraiment la
dernière saison la rade ou pas mais elle
doit en rien en principe ce sera ma
dernière année elle arrêtera pas là le
matin du canadien difficile tu kartonn
je suis sûr que tu vas recompilé brut et
bat le nom alors on va travailler
aujourd'hui tous les deux au paris tous
les appareils tous les deux aujourd'hui
by quoi tu fais pas exprès de ne pas
rempiler je pense que vous laissez un
peu les gens ont reconnu depuis des
années mais et tu sais que je t'aime
mais non mais je sais que c'est dur
parce que les décisions de décembre ne
sont pas les décisions de juin ouais je
n'ai lecture en paix du oui le même
temps oui le matin non je pense pas mais
je parie que tu allais m'a dit c'est
fait on verra on verra un moteur souple
et la photo aux quelque chose rapidement
tous les sociétaires des grosses têtes
étaient présents chantal ladesou
notamment qu'on adorait les fantastiques
mais là lui a un petit problème
d'équilibré pas si vous l'avez vu rien
à
arielle dombasle était là aussi elle a
voulu cela raconté que son accent
anglais manal en place même dans les
monts français l'accent tension pour été
reprise par johnny pas du tout est ce
que ce sont des chansons qui ont été nos
mots à l'oreille
laurent ruquier recevait julien clerc
sans doute pour la dernière fois vu le
petit lapsus sur la prom' ouvre sa rive
son tout nouvel album aller applaudir
julien clerc sur scène pour 755 carrière
c'est beaucoup mais leur tâche de
l'année on le doit à anne sinclair
vous ne ferez pas croire qu'elle fait
pas exprès pour faire passer un message
à quelques heures tous les gens qui sont
ici en ont un
le principal problème c'est l'unité
alors j'ai la chance d'avoir une
baguette dans les mains ça n'est pas
arrivé très souvent
bon c'est pas pour rien qu'elle est
lourd non non juste sur moi petite chose
les amis avant de se dire à l'année
prochaine quelques images de nos
supporters du psg ont ils joué hier on
s'est rendu au parc des princes on est
allé leur demander ce qu'ils pensent et
un petit peu des copains autour de la
table d'hormones même si j'adore ça
c'est le poteau ça franchement beau
gosse et fait rigoler bon présentateur
je n'arrive pas à lui les trimarans et
puis pourquoi ils crient comme sa chérie
tu es mignonne
franchement si on pourra voir en quoi
avec elle n'y a pas de souci flash sur
kelly bon vous emballez paquet lire je
vous cache pas que les autres supporters
est un peu plus direct ans
charmant on pouvait pas terminer l'année
sur notre jeu préféré des maillons bande
les yeux d'enfants la parisien il doit
enfiler un maillot de l'ema en 15
secondes pour le gagner sauf qu'entre
temps on le remplace par celui de
marseille et merci 1 et d'hésitations
marseille auj
wild en revanche nom des gens sur meuse
bahdja des bateaux ont préféré séchant
bat lui les vénère mais il est tellement
bien élevé qui n'osent pas nous renvoyer
le maillot il est trop polis
[ __ ] ses copains
moi je voudrais d'abord remercier tous
les amis merci pour aller jouer hier
c'était là sa dernière chronique de 2017
et reviendront
camus
des trucs de fou fou talent et lassana
diarra truc inhabitable
tami bon il ya rien à 1000 qui m'a
envoyé moi mon chroniqueur de l'année
c'est encore une fois camille combal
voilà pour moi aussi voilà tu as été
exceptionnel encore cette année qualité
pour les contreforts faire citer tous
les soirs c'est un débit différé